It was approximately four thousand years ago
in Finland when people first strapped on skates
to glide across the ice.
This wasn’t for entertainment purposes,
though.
Finland is full of lakes and cutting across
the ice saved time on daily journeys.
By 1 AD, ice skating existed across Northern
Europe.
Metal skates were first created by the Dutch
in 1250 and this led to the proliferation
of leisure skating.
Rinks were built across Europe, but the first
commercial rink in North America was probably
built in Montreal during the mid-19th century.
The first one in the US was Madison Square
Garden ice rink, constructed in 1879.
Of course, keeping the ice frozen, smooth
and safe has always been something of a struggle.
To get around this issue, brothers Joe and
Lester Patrick designed a mechanism for indoor
rinks that utilized brine water to refrigerate
a concrete base, as thin coats of water was
slowly poured over to create layers of ice.
To resurface the ice when it melted and chipped,
the remaining bits of the old ice had to be
removed or smoothed and then this process
was essentially repeated.
But it took a long time and required a large
crew to complete the several-times-a-day task.
Quite simply, there had to be a better way.
It was the turn of the 20th century when Frank
Zamboni was born to recent immigrant parents
in a small town south of Salt Lake City, Utah.
When Zamboni was a baby, his family bought
a farm not too far way in Idaho.
That’s where he got his first experiences
in mechanical engineering.
Frank Zamboni, his brothers and father spent
long hours tinkering and fixing broken farm
equipment.
Frank also worked a local garage, repairing
old pickup trucks.
“While my father never got past the ninth
grade in formal schooling, he always had an
inquisitive mind in solving problems,” Frank’s
son Richard Zamboni later told Popular Mechanics,
“Whether it was electrical, mechanical,
or business-related, he had the unique ability
to get to the heart of issues.”
When Frank was 19, the family moved to Clearwater,
California – a town 15 miles south of Los
Angeles and in the harbor district – because
Frank’s older brother owned a successful
garage there.
Frank helped at the garage and took a second
job as a blacksmith’s apprentice.
Within a year, the family had saved enough
money to send Frank to Chicago’s Coyne Trade
School to study electrical engineering.
When he returned in 1922, Frank and his brothers
opened an electrical company that they would
eventually name “Zamboni Bros. Co.”
They specialized in installing refrigeration
units for the local Dutch-owned dairies that
dominated the small town of Clearwater and
its neighbor Paramount.
Locally, Frank Zamboni became known as a mechanical
and electrical wizard.
In 1928, he registered for his first patent,
a thing called “Adjustable Reactor Resistance“.
In fact, over his lifetime Frank Zamboni would
be awarded 15 patents, including one for the
Astro Zamboni Machine, which was designed
to suck up water from AstroTurf at a rate
of about 400 gallons per minute.
In the late 1920s, the brothers used their
refrigeration know-how to open an ice-making
plant that kept local fruits and vegetables
fresh and cold as they were being shipped
across the country via train.
However, already by then, freon was being
successfully used in commercial refrigeration.
By the 1930s, refrigerators became something
anyone could have in their home.
Within only a few years of the Zamboni Brothers
starting their ice-making plant, it was obsolete.
So, in January 1940 and using their ice-making
skills, they opened a 20,000 square foot ice
skating rink across the street from their
former business.
It was called Iceland and it was one of the
largest ice rinks in the country.
So, why would the Zamboni brothers build a
humongous ice skating rink in a Southern California
town that was miles away from Los Angeles?
Because of the local Dutch population, for
whom skating had become a part of everyday
life starting in the 13th century (in particular,
speed skating).
The rink was an immediate hit, attracting
150,000 people a year.
But they had problems – mostly due to the
omnipresent Southern California sun.
Although the brothers quickly added a roof
and Frank had installed a new and improved
version of what the Patrick brothers did in
Canada, the ice did not stay frozen for long
and often melted.
Thus, it required constant attention from
a large crew that needed more than an hour
to manually resurface the ice.
The process was inefficient and time-consuming.
So, Frank Zamboni – the most skilled engineer
of a family full of them – got to work.
It took more than seven years, parts pulled
from all over and several failed models, but
by 1949, Zamboni had a working prototype for
an “ice resurfacer.”
He started with two Dodge truck front ends,
which he used for both the front and back.
He put in a transmission, a front steering
axle that provided four wheel drive and a
Jeep engine – all from war surplus junkyards.
Zamboni then tacked on a tractor seat, a chalice
from an oil derrick and the landing gear of
a Douglas A-26 bomber.
Finally, he added elements to the souped-up
ice-traveling tractor that shaved and resurfaced
the ice – razor blades, a paddle and chain
system, a wood box to catch the savings, another
tank with hot water and a towel to spread
the water on the ice.
In the summer of 1949, with the ever present
California sun glowing hot, he debuted his
“Model A Zamboni Ice Resurfacer.”
It was top-heavy, bizarrely complicated to
control, and loud.
But it worked, requiring only one operator
and about ten minutes to create a smooth new
sheet of ice.
(This first unit was used at Iceland for several
years and is now on display at the still-existing
ice rink as a piece of American history.)
Soon after, Zamboni patented his ice resurfacer,
formed a partnership with his brothers that
he called “Frank J. Zamboni & Co” and
went to work on Model B. Tinkering and improving
the machine, he made his first sale – to
nearby Pasadena Winter Gardens- for $5,000.
The next one (and third one) he built for
Norwegian Olympian (and movie star) Sonja
Henie, who had seen the Zamboni in action
while she practiced for her “Hollywood on
Ice” show at Iceland.
(On that note, it’s unclear when the name
of the machine shifted from “ice resurfacer”
to the name of the inventor, but legend has
it that Henie was the one who asked Frank
to give her one of those “Zambonis.”)
Whatever the case, the fourth Zamboni was
sold to the Ice Capades.
That one is now on display at the Hockey Hall
of Fame.
The Zamboni made its NHL debut in 1952 during
a Boston Bruins game, forever cementing the
relationship between the machine and the sport.
Over six decades later, the Zamboni is a cultural
icon, inspiring fandom beyond anyone’s wildest
imagination.
After all, it was merely built to make a cold,
wet job easier.
“I don’t understand it,” the baffled
inventor told the Los Angeles Times in 1988,
“I was just trying to find a better way
of doing something.”